[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and i can't
believe that we're finally in the end
game now after an agonizing wait
spider-man noah home is now out and
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down the movie explaining the
ending and also talking about where the
franchise could be going in the future
your spoiler sense should be tingling
right now as we're going to be going
through it all so if you haven't seen it
then get out of here at breakneck speed
like gwen stacy you're my eyes and ears
out here so if you enjoy the video then
please hit the thumbs up button and
don't forget to subscribe without the
way it's pizza time now let's scooby do
this [ __ ] and get into spiderman no way
home
okay so if you're here without seeing
the movie and just want to know whether
the big leak was true or not then i'll
say up top that andrew garfield and toby
maguire are both in the film andrew is
indeed the werewolf we got to look at
toby mcguire's dick and i'm so glad that
everyone who's been saying this for
years can now rest we can rest now
beyond that though no way home has a
number of big surprises in it and it's
the most fun i've had in the theater
since avengers endgame now i am going to
be calling the spider-man by their actor
names as referring to them as peter 1 2
and 3 will get confusing but each one of
them brings something special to the
film the movie picks up immediately
after the events are far from home with
peter's identity out there and he has to
live with the repercussions of his
newfound fame they even got some of the
actors back from that scene including
this guy who shows up in both films nice
now though his name is cleared by none
other than matt murdock his life and the
life of his friends has been ruined by
the court of public opinion and their
applications to mit are indeed rejected
the group can't get into any schools at
all and it's clear that even though they
didn't do anything wrong they've been
cancelled conspiracy theories surround
the webhead and there's a large group of
team mysterio that believe peter is a
murderer thus they have to move into
happy's apartment which just so happens
to have dummy there who you might
recognize from the iron man movies we
also catch dalmon in queens which was a
deli peter visited in homecoming and he
also wears a t-shirt that tony gave him
in that movie the lives are all ruined
though and thus peter goes to doctor
strange in order to erase his knowledge
from everyone's minds so that his
friends lives can have somewhat
normality however his constant
interrupting during this causes it to
shatter the multiverse and it brings
across people from other franchises that
now peter parker is spider-man this
includes a number of his enemies most
notably the green goblin who is played
once more by willem dafoe to make
matters worse the spell doesn't actually
work but we do end with it being cast
once more which pretty much destroys all
of the friendships and relationships
that peter has now they do change up
some scenes from the trailers namely the
setup to the spell and whereas the
teasers had some corners of the internet
believing that strange was mephisto it's
clear he's just trying to help peter as
best he can see
see i knew i knew it couldn't be
mephisto
he doesn't exist now the movie actually
pulls from several comic story lines and
it includes elements of civil war one
more day and also happy birthday in the
civil war run peter unmasked for the
entire world during a pr stunt to show
the positives of the superhuman
registration act this sent the marvel
universe into a civil war in which iron
man and captain america went head to
head over the accords peter ended up
switching sides from tony to steve but
with his identity already out there it
put those around him in a lot of danger
kingpin sent assassins after him and
during an attack they shot aunt may and
left her in critical condition desperate
to save her life peter went to doctor
strange in a run-down sanctum sanctorum
and asked him to cast a spell that would
allow him to delve into multiple
timelines and asked for help from every
scientific mind however they all said
there was nothing that they could do and
thus peter turned to someone else
mephisto showed up to 10 peter and he
pledged to heal and may but in return he
wanted peter and mary jane's love peter
and mary jane ended up sacrificing their
marriage to save may and to make sure
that no one ever came after those he
loved again peter also stipulated that
the world had to forget he was
spider-man beyond that the happy
birthday storyline had dormammu
attacking new york and peter interrupted
a spell that strange was casting which
opened up reality itself inside this
void peter came across two versions of
himself from the past and future which
of course reflects the other two
spider-man that we get in this entry and
there are several easter eggs hinting
towards their arrival and lots of things
that call back to the previous movies
this includes toby's back being busted
up which in spider-man 2 was actually a
naughty toby sustaining a back injury
that meant he was almost recast with
jake gyllenhaal now after the villains
are brought across peter ends up going
to an mit staff member to try and
convince her to let his friends in
before he has a chance to plead his case
though dr octopus attacks and peter ends
up going head-to-head with him during
this battle arc actually slices peter's
tie off and the suit and even the kurta
callbacks to spider-man 3 when toby
maguire's version had the exact same
thing happen to him peter manages to
take control of his tender goals through
the nanotech overriding them and thus
he's able to subdue otto however the
green goblin arrives but just before
peter can take him on he's transported
below the sanctorum where otto is
imprisoned along with the lizard who had
a run-in with strange from this point on
peter is ordered to capture the villains
along with ned and mj and they have to
scooby doo this [ __ ] not crap [ __ ] now
he finds electro draining power out in
the woods and i need to jump over to the
multiverse myself because man the glow
up on this dude is incredible here peter
is helped by sandman but he ends up
transporting them both to the prison
which sort of sews some seeds of doubt
in the character that appear later on
now we also catch up with osborne
talking to his mask like in the movies
but he ends up smashing it before
fleeing to feast the way the mask is
shattered does somewhat resemble the way
that toby dumped his costume behind in
spider-man 2 and you do kind of get the
feeling that osborne may have defeated
the darkness within him after finding
him at the shelter maine still the idea
on peter that he has to help these
people and thus upon returning to the
sanctuarium and finding that they're
gonna die he decides to take mattis into
his own hands peter ends up stealing the
spell which is contained within a cube
known as the cob cobalogwa
magic box now this leads to a chase
across the mirror dimension in which
peter best strange steals his sling ring
and leaves him trapped there he sets out
to cure the villains and they return to
happy's home in order to use the machine
that we saw and far from home this can
develop items to save them the first of
which is a chip to replace the broken
one in otto's neck and this will allow
him to regain control of his mind on a
side tangent whilst we're here i never
got why the miniature sun was such a big
draw in spider-man 2 when this guy had
developed arms that he could control
with his mind should have been a massive
thing that they marketed there but no no
just kind of used it to control
something else and no one paid attention
to them anyway bit of a gripe there and
moving on now peter develops a device
that can draw energy from electro and
along with norman they start to work on
removing the goblin however this ends up
taking over norman and it talks electro
into destroying the device so that they
can become gods in this reality electro
steals the ark reactor that's powering
the workbench sandman leaves and lizard
runs off into the night with news
cameras at the scene and being attacked
by his own pals otto flees too which
leaves peter and the goblin to go head
to head osbourne easily bests him and in
the lobby he knocks mae down with his
glider before launching a pumpkin bomb
at her initially she seems fine however
in the wreckage she collapses and dies
after saying with grey power comes great
responsibility
i wasn't crying yeah you you were crying
and happy is arrested at the scene he
then screams run peter run and then your
boy flees to a rooftop where he spent a
lot of time with mj away from the world
now across town ned and nj are desperate
to find him and using strange's sling
ring the former manages to open a portal
upon saying that he wishes he could find
peter parker this not only brings across
andrew but later toby when the spell is
repeated and this scene is one of the
most impactful ones i've seen in a
cinema for a long time it was so good
seeing them back and garfield especially
knocks it out of the park whenever he's
on screen now though ned leeds in the
comics went on to become the hobgoblin
it does seem like they're doing
something different with him and that
he'll become a sorcerer at some point
after getting some lip service to harry
osborne he does vow to never turn on
peter but in the aftermath of the ending
who knows if that's gonna be the case
now toby andrew and tom have some
incredible scenes together that touch
upon gwen uncle ben their web shooters
and there's even references to the
spider-man pointing meme together they
create cures for the villains and
announce through the daily bugle that
they'll all be at the new and improved
statue of liberty this is where it all
goes down and together the spider-man
work with one another to administer the
cures these include the ones seen at the
end of the amazing spider-man a reverse
collider for sandman and ox shows up to
help out with electro everything is
coming at milhouse until the green
goblin arrives he ends up grabbing the
cube and putting a pumpkin bomb in it
which blows reality wide open and we
start to see several villains entering
the mcu this includes the likes of the
rhino either scorpion or a spider slayer
and there's several amongst this that
would completely decimate the world ned
and mj are pulled into the fray but
andrew gets his redemption when he saves
mj from falling which is something that
he couldn't do with gwen peter almost
killed goblin for what he did to may but
at the last second he stopped from
ramming a glider into his face by toby
maguire toby gets stabbed but andrew
tosses the cure to tom who injects
goblin and then cures him of his kevin
spoiler's side the villains and their
spider-man have mended their
relationships and they'll now return to
their own universes to escape the deaths
that were bound to happen with them may
very much instilled in tom the idea that
if he saves one person he saves everyone
and thus he stopped a lot of heartbreak
from happening in other realities
however reality is still tearing apart
but peter realizes that if strange casts
the spell to make everyone forget he's
spider-man that this will stop it from
ripping open he has a tearful goodbye
with mj and promises that he'd come and
tell both her and ned about himself so
that they can remember him once more he
ventures out to where mj works one day
and the emotion in the scene is
absolutely incredible it's clear he has
this entire thing planned out and then
he knows exactly what he wants to say
but when ned enters and the pair talk
about mit he starts to have second
thoughts mj even has the black dahlia
necklace that he bought her and far from
home but she simply can't remember that
they've ever met after noticing a
band-aid covering a cut that she got at
the statue of liberty he decides to
leave both her and ned as she seems
happier and being close to him will only
put her in danger this was very much a
motif that was brought up by the end of
the first rhymie film and peter had to
turn away from the person he loved in
order to spare them the pain that his
lifestyle would cause it's completely
devastating and it's arguably one of the
most painful endings to an mcu movie
ever to make matters worse peter visits
mae's grave and he's then joined by
happy who doesn't recognize him either
however he alludes to tony and what
may's death meant which pushes peter on
even though he's now at his lowest point
you could play lonely by akon over these
scenes and we end with him moving into
his first apartment by himself though
there's no mr dikovich here he'll
clearly start using this as a base of
operations and he'll continue to help
people peter is picking up police
frequencies and he's also made his
costume which looks just like the
classic suit that comes from the comics
it's a bittersweet ending that shows
peter has been inspired by those he
loves and though they've forgotten what
he meant to them he hasn't forgotten
what they meant to him now there are a
couple of things i want to touch upon
and with the villains getting reformed
and sent back to their own timelines we
could be getting some big things down
the line though no sequels have been
announced sony are never ones to turn
down paychecks and we could potentially
get another maguire or garfield film and
potentially even one for the bad guys
them being reformed could somewhat be
hinting at a possible dark avengers
group headed up by none other than
norman osborne in the comics after the
events of civil war osborne was
appointed to create his own team of
superheroes and with this being so
closely linked to the events of the
comics we may be heading in that
direction lady loki was also a member
and with the disney plus show loki
introducing a similar character to her
that could be the way that they're
heading there's also some lip service
given to miles morales as elektro says
he hopes there's a universe out there
where spider-man is black as for peter
and mj knowing that he had to sacrifice
their love in order for her to be okay
is something that stuck with me long
after i left the theater as we mentioned
earlier this is somewhat similar to one
more day's storyline in which their love
was taken away from them whilst the
devil who's always in the details
doesn't show up in this movie it's
clearly centered around that idea and we
could use the comics to guess where
things are going now mj and peter
weren't always together in the source
material and at one point she actually
dated brad who you might remember from
far from home brad and mj was somewhat
getting close in that film but mj went
all in with peter after learning he was
spider-man however without this
knowledge it might mean that she did go
back to him now as for the future i
think this might actually open up the
possibility that another love interest
could end up peter's life though
garfield's version of the character
somewhat hindered towards gwen i could
see her coming into the mcu and who
knows we may even get a version of
spider-gwen in this universe however it
could also allow marvel studios to
introduce black cat who at the moment
hasn't really featured in a film though
felicity jones played felicia in amazing
spider-man 2 she and peter never came
face to face and she didn't get it on
her costume either so i would love to
see her get brought into the films as i
think that would really add an
interesting dynamic to the mcu felicia
brings a lot of attitude to the
character and who knows tom's version
might end up getting some too if more of
his personality aspects are enhanced by
what's left behind in the post-credits
scene i'm not going to talk about the
second one in this video and if you're
here without watching the movie then
i'll just say that that's because it's
actually a trailer for doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness i'm gonna save
my breakdown of that until after that
releases online to promote the film as
i'd rather just do a separate video what
i want to talk about though is the one
involving tom hardy's eddie brock which
follows on from the events of venom that
debbie carnage in that movie we watched
as venom was about to show eddie a
fraction of what his species had done to
the cosmos but they were pulled across
into the mcu on a tv in the hotel room
we saw as a news report by j jonah
jameson announced that spider-man was
peter parker and venom said he looks
tasty before licking the screen now all
you people who thought that venom was
gonna be in the mcu you'll probably be
disappointed by the post-credits scene
as it sends him home just as quickly as
he arrived honestly it kind of feels
like foggy just allowed venom to come
into the mcu so that they could yoink
the symbiote off him and then send him
back to the sony verse aka hell just
kidding sony i love you now eddie is in
mexico and he's sad about getting filled
in on the events of the past he's
shocked to learn that there's tons of
superheroes in this reality as in his
he's the only one he recounts things
like iron man and says there's a belly
now with a tin suit that can fly an
angry green man and a purple alien who
loves stones eddie then says that maybe
he should go to new york and speak to
this spider-man before being pulled out
of the mcu
whilst his stay was short and sweet he
does leave behind a piece of the
symbiote on the bar which now has the
idea instilled in it that it should
travel to nyc i'm sure all of you know
that in the car makes peter ends up
getting a black suit during the events
of secret wars which later turns out to
be a parasitic symbiote that brings out
the darker parts of his personality
pierre managed to remove this and it
ended up infecting a rival at the daily
bugle named eddie brock now we don't
know whether the eddie brock of this
universe will be played by tom hardy or
not but the way that things have been
done is a bit weird originally marvel
studios didn't have the rights to use
venom so sony went ahead with their own
franchise i kind of hope the one from
the sony verse does get pulled across
otherwise the order of things will
basically be that we get a venom in a
separate universe who's completely
unaware of spider-man he goes into the
mcu leaves behind some of the symbiote
goes back to his own universe that
symbiote then attaches to peter we then
get the black suit saga which ends with
eddie being infected which seems like
the weirdest way that they could have
laid this all out saying that though i
am excited to see what they do and it
has been reported that tom holland has
signed on to do three more solo
spider-man movies i think that harry
osborn could potentially be introduced
during this time and other characters
like felicia who would complement the
personality changes that the venom
symbiote brings out as long as we don't
get any dancing down the street it
should be good and it's going to be
interesting to see how they take things
we might even get another gwen stacey
orc and though some people could think
it's too soon after garfield to do that
we did have mary jane with toby and then
mj in the mcu i can imagine they'd
handle gwen completely differently like
how they did with mj and it'll be
interesting to see the direction that
they take things i do however want to
see peter back with mj and i just hope
that they get get their happy ending i'm
not i'm not crying either now that kind
of takes me into my thoughts on the film
and though i loved it i did have some
issues with it early on i think it's
only fair to talk about both my
negatives and positives as i'm not
someone who just wants to say
everything's amazing best movie ever no
problems now i did feel like the first
tower was pretty choppy and a bit all
over the place at points i think the
issue was that it had to wrap up the
mysterio cliffhanger whilst also saying
i'm the multiverse storyline so some
things didn't get the proper time and
development that i believe they required
now i had some weird issues whilst i was
watching at the cinema and they actually
ended up having to restart the film five
times i saw the first 10 minutes over
and over and over again because the
cinema had an issue that they just
couldn't seem to fix and thus that might
be a factor as to why i was a bit meh on
the opening however as soon as willem
default ends the movie the film gets
incredible and it somehow gets better
and better every single scene though a
lot of this movie was leaked going into
it and watching the moments play out was
so much fun and it's going to be
interesting to see if marvel can top
this i know that everyone said avengers
endgame was the peak but feel that this
is up there and bringing so many
elements from the past together to tell
an incredible story toby mcguire brings
a real wisdom to the screen and garfield
for me he's my favorite spider-man ever
at this point now there's also that
heartbreaking ending which i actually
think might be the best standing to a
marvel movie ever it's difficult to
think what i'd put above it and it just
shows the sacrifice that comes with
being a hero though i did have problems
with the first hour they were long
forgotten when we properly got into the
movie and i was enjoying it so much that
i felt strange and cast a memory spell
on me all the issues just went away and
i love the hell out of it this is
definitely the best mcu spider-man film
and though i'd still play spider-man 2
and into the spider verse above it i
still had such a good time with it
spider-man no way home was brilliant and
it gets a 9 out of 10. now obviously i'd
love to hear your thoughts so make sure
you comment below and let me know if you
want something else to watch then make
sure you check out our breakdown of
hawkeye which will be linked on screen
right now we've gone over the entire
thing from top to bottom and talking
about all the easter eggs in it so
definitely go check it out right after
this without the way thank you for
singing through the video i've been paul
i'll see you in the next one take care
peace